[Music]
pain
is one of the most trying experiences of
life
on the cellular level it is communicated
via special neuronal pathways on the
molecular level however
pain is communicated like any other
sensation
by a set of electrical and chemical
signals facilitated by complex molecular
machinery
along the neuronal membrane the signal
travels much like electric current along
a wire
this process is mediated by membrane
proteins called voltage-gated ion
channels
voltage-gated ion channels open or close
in reaction to changes in membrane
voltage or membrane potential these
proteins have special voltage sensing
domains that are coupled to ion channels
when a neuron is at rest its ion
channels are closed
a cell membrane potential is generated
by concentration gradients of positively
charged sodium and potassium ions across
the membrane
when the neuron is at rest the overall
concentrations of ions and proteins
create higher potential in the outside
and lower on the inside
this state is referred to as resting
potential and the membrane is said to be
polarized
to transmit signal the neuron creates an
action potential which travels down the
axon
the action potential is mediated by the
opening of the voltage-gated sodium
channels
which allows sodium to enter the neuron
this depolarizes the membrane in the
local area
neurons then repolarize the membrane in
several ways
stopping the action potential first
voltage-gated sodium channels close and
become inactivated
then to counteract the positive charge
of the sodium ions
potassium channels start to open
allowing potassium ions to exit
and lowering the voltage across the
membrane
finally after a short refractory period
sodium channels open the inactivation
gates and ion pumps restore the resting
potential in preparation for the next
signal
in this way the signal travels along the
neuron sodium channels open and trigger
one another to generate action
potentials
and potassium channels then stop the
action potential in the local area
once the action potential arrives at the
end of the neuron
it is transferred to the next cell at a
place called a synapse
the synaptic region contains membrane
vesicles filled with small molecules
called neurotransmitters
which will conduct the signal upon
release into the synaptic cleft
this process is dependent on the
presence of calcium ions inside the cell
because intracellular calcium is sparse
while extracellular calcium is abundant
voltage-gated calcium channels are
essential in this process
the positive charges of the traveling
action potential activate these proteins
causing the ion channels to open and
allowing calcium inside the cell
calcium then activates other proteins
that help the vesicle to merge with the
neuronal membrane
creating an opening for the
neurotransmitters to enter the synaptic
cleft
there are many types of
neurotransmitters one of them
glutamate is shown here binding to its
receptor
this receptor has an ion channel which
opens upon glutamate binding
and allows ions to enter the cell
initiating a new action potential that
will travel along the axon
thus allowing the message to be passed
along
these signals can be modulated on the
molecular level causing us to feel less
pain
or no pain at all
our bodies produce natural painkillers
known as endorphins and keflans and
dynorphins
the peptide showed here is an encephalin
these natural painkillers are mimicked
by opioid drugs
one of the most widely used opioids is
morphine which is derived from the opium
poppy
both natural painkillers and opioids
activate the same inhibitory receptors
called
opioid receptors
opioid receptors are part of a large
class of g-protein-coupled receptors or
gpcrs
gpcrs are nested in cellular membranes
with the opioid binding site on the
outside of the cell
inside the cell the receptors are
coupled to g proteins
g proteins have three distinct subunits
alpha
beta and gamma an inactive g
protein has gdp bound to its alpha
subunit
upon opioid binding the gdp be is
released at gtp
binds instead releasing the g protein
from the receptor
causing the alpha subunit to separate
from the beta and gamma subunits
the beta gamma subunit interacts
directly with ion channels
stopping the signal for example the beta
gamma subunit can bind to special
potassium channels
causing them to remain open and allow
potassium to exit the cell
this lowers the electric potential
inside the cell and eventually leads to
the dissipation of the action potential
the beta gamma subunit can prevent
neurotransmitter release by binding to
voltage-gated calcium channels
this prevents the activation of the
channels
as a result calcium is unable to enter
the cell and the release of
neurotransmitters is halted
there are several types of g-alpha
subunit that couple to different gpcrs
two types of g-alpha subunit can
interact with the enzyme adenylyl
cyclase
these are inhibitory and stimulatory
g-alpha
opioid receptors are always coupled to
inhibitory g-alpha
in the presence of stimulatory g-alpha
adenylyl cyclase uses atp
to produce cyclic amp cyclic amp is
often called a second messenger
because it amplifies the signal
generated by the first messengers
the neurotransmitters
cyclic amp can activate some ion
channels indirectly via protein kinases
and activate other ion channels directly
both activities augment the ion flow
regulating the neuronal signal
when opioid receptors are activated the
g-alpha inhibitory subunit inhibits
adenylyl cyclase
preventing the production of cyclic amp
as a result
the signal is dampened
opioid drugs are a great boon in pain
management when used for a limited time
and is prescribed by a physician
however the possibility of overdose is a
danger
as opioids can deactivate neuronal
circuits other than those responsible
for pain signaling
causing severe side effects or even
death
during an overdose drugs like naloxone
are used to save lives
naloxone is similar in structure to
opioids and binds in a similar location
on the receptor but does not activate
the g protein
as a result it makes the receptors
unavailable to opioids
by studying opioid receptors scientists
are currently trying to discover new
non-addictive compounds that can bind to
these receptors in order to create safe
[Music]
painkillers
[Music]
[Music]
you